[Music]
when I say the word energy what does
that bring to mind what do you think of
I because I'm an engineer I think about
how we produce energy I think about
fossil fuels I think about solar energy
I think actually I think about climate
change and how our energy behavior is
influencing the greenhouse effect but
there's a much more positive way to
think about energy when you think about
energy is the basis for life it's the
basis of food how do we turn our water
into clean water it's with energy how do
we power our health our healthcare
system are especially our advanced
technologies for health it's with energy
energy is a huge business and energy
enables both the basics of life like
transportation and the luxuries of life
like some of our transportation forms
now with it being such a powerful basis
of life in society it's not surprising
that we should be thinking about how our
demand for it is going to be growing and
this plot really illustrates the
potential for huge growth in our needs
our consumption for energy we call the
horizontal axis the effluence axis its
GDP per capita and I'm going to call the
vertical axis the energy axis its energy
per capita now look on the top right
you'll see the affluent nations of the
world obviously we're consuming places
like the US and Western Europe in
Australia we're consuming a lot of
energy per citizen but look closer to
the origin look on the bottom left of
this graph and you'll see China India
and Brazil and you'll see that today
their GDP per capita is relatively low
and you'll also see correspondingly
their energy uptake per capita is
relatively low but are these nations
with small populations I mean these are
our billion person nations are they
going to be growing along the horizontal
axis are they experiencing this huge
economic growth
in the developing nations such as these
of course they are
and in view of this correlation they're
going to be experiencing a huge energy
demand growth as well what's that going
to do well it puts us in a position of
an energy deficit I mean if you're
worried about our current habits for
energy consumption and fossil fuel
consumption and carbon dioxide emission
well just think about what's going to
happen there's going to be a doubling in
our energy demand over the coming couple
of decades as shown in this plot on the
left is shown what we do today about 80%
of our energy needs are fulfilled using
fossil fuels but when we double what's
going to fill up this question mark are
we going to just burn more fossil fuels
well I have good news that probably
didn't sound like it yet but I have some
good news this problem of meeting our
energy needs sustainably and cleanly
this is actually a solved problem this
has been done before not by people not
by engineers or scientists such as
myself but it's done by nature so that's
huge 15 terawatts of power consumption
that I was talking about all of a sudden
I'm gonna squeeze it down on this plot
and show that level of global energy
consumption of 15 terrawatts and I'm
going to compare it on the right with
what photosynthesis does so nature is
already fulfilling a tenfold larger
energy need through photosynthesis
what's it doing at a most basic level
that's taking the sun's energy it's
converting it into stored biomass which
is stored fuel and in the course of it
it's eating up it's consuming and
sequestering carbon dioxide so if it's a
solved problem is it something that we
could learn about is it something that
people who work on new solar cell
technologies where we're trying to make
them efficient but we're also trying to
make them cheap we're trying to put
solar technologies everywhere to open
our arms wide to catch the sun's rays is
it something where we can learn from
what nature has already solved and
that's the question that our see far
emerging program proposes to look at
and in particular we think there there's
specific ideas from nature that we can
learn from and it's these ideas that we
want to tackle I'm going to illustrate
three of them the first one is that
Nature has figured out how to carry out
energy transport within the
photosynthetic apparatus with remarkable
ease and efficiency and we have hints of
how and these hints tell us that this
cannot be explained purely using
classical physics Newton's laws don't
allow us to understand fully how light
gets absorbed and exit ons which are
excitation coming from the Sun
transferred into plants in the form of
excited electrons how they migrate we
need the rules of quantum mechanics we
need this fascinating duality these
ideas of wave functions and
Schrodinger's uncertainty principle we
need these ideas of coherence to
understand how nature achieves it's
remarkably efficient transport of energy
we don't fully understand it how we just
know that it's needed and a new field
has emerged called quantum biology to
try to study this and understand it
deeply we also know that Nature has
found ways to make incredibly efficient
use of this broad rainbow that is the
sun's energy so if you think of a bunch
of algae that stratify they form
spontaneously as a community in a pond
well they will sequester and the ones on
top will reach out and capture the blue
and the ultraviolet part of the Sun
spectrum and the ones in the middle will
do the green and then the ones further
down will do the red and then there will
even be infrared ones at the bottom of
the pond and so Nature has figured out
ways to take full advantage almost a
prism out display out the Sun spectrum
and to make fully efficient use of it
there's another remarkable inspiration
in nature and it's so far from what
engineers do today when we think of
building solar cells nature employs
self-repair if one of the proteins
that's inside a plant's photosynthetic
apparatus if it gets damaged maybe an
overly energetic photon impinges on it
or gets a little bit too hot well rather
than give up it will repair it it will
transport it away to another region
and actually use a little bit of solar
energy to repair that protein now this
is just entirely counter to the way
today's engineers think about making
solar technologies we think about making
something that has to be so perfect so
pure that it will last without change
without alteration for 25 years it's a
completely different paradigm what if we
could change the way we think and think
instead about building self repair into
our solar cells into the means by which
we generate solar fuels so I a my
colleagues scoured the world in order to
find the leading people around the globe
who think about these problems but these
problems in all of their dimensions we
sought to bring together a community
that would include biologists and photo
biologists and quantum biologists that
would include people who build new
materials materials chemists people who
think about how to make a device work
well and people who would engineer these
into practical solutions and we sought
to bring them together because we
thought that only by bringing this group
together could we address this
incredibly important problem in an
innovative way really take us off the
path off the course that is so far been
charted by this community and we would
seek to create a pipeline of ideas going
from basic science from from new
concepts really speaking across
different languages of science and
engineering that that community speaks
today and transform these new ideas from
science into practical new solar
electricity technologies and means of
directly taking light from the Sun and
turning it into fuels solar fuels and
that we would have a further component
of actually transforming these into
technologies in the context of our
emergency fire program we also recognize
that this is not something that we can
do on our own this is not a purely
academic problem there are people from
industry from companies large and small
who have been working on relatives of
this problem for decades and then we
have a lot to learn from them and so a
key dimension to our CFR program will be
engaging with stakeholders especially
from the sustainable energy industry and
from the energy sector broadly
in order to bring solutions to these
problems you know this is a global
challenge obviously climate change
energy but I'm actually really
passionate about the Canadian dimension
here I and my colleagues have a dream
that Canada could be the locus of
innovation of the creation of a new
sustainable energy economy based on
incredibly innovative bio-inspired
technologies you know that in a couple
of years the energy sector is going to
be a ten trillion dollar industry so
there's a huge societal opportunity
there's a huge economic opportunity as
well from learning from nature and
that's the challenge that we're about to
embark on thank you
[Applause]
[Music]